so I love the art style of Elden Rings
map and what I especially love are the
little design flourishes that you can
find along the coastline swirling
maelstroms give the impression of a sea
in upheaval and the broken ships dotted
around the place only reinforce that
idea now we could go into speculation on
who owned these ships and small vessels
but what I find far more interesting
than the lore in this case is actually
what inspired these sorts of design
flourishes on Elden Ring's map which
brings us to this Paolo forlani's 16th
century maps of the world which feature
outlandish creatures and ships that look
really similar to the designs in Elden
Ring's map now there are no sea monsters
found in Elden Rings maps in the current
version at least in the older versions
of the map however there were tons of
monsters so what you're looking at now
is a much older map of lim Gray
something that was Data mined by Chinese
players from an earlier version of the
game
and this one has a mermaid taken
straight out of Paolo forlani's as well
as creatures lifted straight from a ton
of other Maps as well confirming these
ancient Inspirations and giving us a ton
more to discuss besides because all of
this text is actually readable
so originally posted on Billy Billy a
Chinese video sharing website a channel
whose name I don't want to mispronounce
posted a video covering the script found
on the original map and on this original
map they found Chinese characters from
the Yi script and despite that language
kind of Fading Into Obscurity the group
was able to translate the Yi characters
through a series of events detailed in
the video below and translated by the
YouTube channel yys TV so to break some
of this down some of the text separates
the C's surrounding the Weeping
Peninsula into four distincties the
north east south and west Seas but much
of the older text is actually written as
warning here for example it says
multiple witnesses to a sea serpent
danger and we do indeed see these
serpents spliced from other medieval sea
charts and inserted straight into the
map
do you remember the bridge of sacrifice
that leads to the Weeping Peninsula well
in this earlier version the channel that
runs under it is called a kraken Channel
suggesting that it'd be a very dangerous
route for any ships to take the Kraken
itself is found Elsewhere on the map as
well with this image that is roughly
taken from an engraving made in 1801 so
to be clear I'm not suggesting that
these sea monsters are canon in Eldon
Ring's law or anything like that if
anything it's actually more the opposite
these were only ever intended as
internal references for from software
and the fact that no sea monsters
survived onto Elden Ring's actual map
means that maybe from software found
these inclusions to be distracting since
they never really Drew any new monsters
of their own so in the end we were left
with these boats small excerpts of
blurred text and were left with this
story of an older map that inspired it
all and I'm a huge sucker for this older
version of and Rings map because it's
such a rare fascinating glimpse into a
past aspect of the game's development
the reason that data mining and early
assets are so intriguing to the souls
Community is because we don't really
hear much from the developers when it
comes to the development process they
usually just give a few interviews at
release time and then they disappear
heads down on the next project Miyazaki
has even gone on record saying that he
probably won't end up playing Elden ring
because and I quote I just don't enjoy
playing the games that I've made in the
past once they're done they're done now
George RR Martin was involved this time
as well though unfortunately he hasn't
gone into much detail about the
characters and story that he created
either leaving us all wondering what he
created and what was tweaked by Miyazaki
and the team I know George doesn't
really play video games but it'd be
really cool if nemco got him to watch a
playthrough to see reactions to his
characters or I'd love to see him
comment on his creative process in a bit
more detail but anyway in a recent
interview with Stephen Colbert George
did mention one tidbit that helped us
with Elden Ring's timeline but they made
it clear that Elden ring was going to
take place in uh let's say the present
of their game universe but what they
wanted me to write was what happened
like 5 000 years before that that
totally screwed up the world so that the
president was really messed up so
assuming that this wasn't like an
offhand comment now we at least know
that a period of 5 000 years might have
passed between the shattering and the
events of the game for number four as
many of you know in an earlier version
of the game the character vike played a
more important role and it's actually
him that we see on the cover art of
Elden ring he's almost like the chosen
one the main character that was supposed
to become Eldon Lord so much so that
he's even featured on the game's cover
but something went tragically wrong with
his story and our character takes over
instead it's cool to me that he's still
represented as as the main character
that's how close he got to becoming
Elden Lord you know but vike isn't the
only recognizable element on the olden
ring cover for example here are two
Divine Towers here is a statue you might
recognize it's the one that always
stands atop Heroes grave sites here is a
collapsed Dragon like the one in
godric's Boss room and surrounding vike
in his fingerprint set I've also found
five bodies that wear five very familiar
armor sets there's the Royal remains set
here the champion set here you can tell
because of the red little tassel the
carrion Knight set the iron set although
it could also be the Kaiden set I think
and The Eccentric set that jiren wears
right here if there's anything else I'm
missing in this image please let me know
so for number five there's an item
called soft cotton that reduces the
amount of fall damage you take in Elden
ring as if you'd ever need it but anyway
so soft cotton is a craftable item and
it only requires a rower fruit and a
smoldering butterfly to create when I
saw this recently I wondered why the
butterfly and then after reading the
item descriptions more closely I
realized that the cotton is created by
splitting open rower fruit in a
particular manner so since the
smoldering butterfly is involved this
particular manner must involve burning
the rower fruit popping it open to
release the soft cotton this could also
explain why humans are unable to ingest
rower fruit as stated by the roller
raisin description since it's
essentially just cotton on the inside
next I want to talk about finger Maiden
theralina this character that appears at
the Redan Festival upon interacting with
her you'll notice she doesn't talk she
only bows this is kind of strange but it
gets weirder when you consider her
spirit item description it reads Spirit
of a finger Maiden who never met the
tarnished she was meant to guide uses
healing incantations and holy water pots
but she is not a fighter by nature and
is ill-suited to battle a maiden without
a tarnished a tarnished without a maiden
and yet no guide to bring them together
so why would tharalina who is ill-suited
to battle appear at Redan Festival which
is entirely about celebrating battle
well what if she was sent here
feralina is actually one of celevis's
puppets and here crumpled in a heap in
sullivas's basement is therolina herself
so in a similar way to how Rani sent
Blythe and yourself to kill radon it
seems like Rani might have instructed
celibus to assist us here as well
leading to him sending thoralina as a
puppet in his stead and as ill-suited to
combat as she supposedly is you know she
probably wouldn't have sought out this
fight herself she does cast healing
spells for allies which makes her the
perfect Ally to be sent to this battle
in a way speaking of spirit summons did
you know that you can summon Euro to
help you against flying dragon agile a
few people know about this because the
requirements for getting his help are
kind of absurd first you have to defeat
bloody fingerius with Yuri's help and
then speak to him after the battle in
this dark area where he's easy to miss
and then he'll warn you to stay away
from the lake but if you blatantly
disregard this and fall in battle
against a gill you have to die here you
can return to Europe who will scold you
for ignoring his advice and then he'll
come to terms with the fact that you're
going to fight the dragon anyway and
then you're a summon sign will appear on
subsequent attempts at her Gil so
considering all of this considering that
you have to die to a Gill and then seek
out Yura as if you knew he would have
more dialogue for you that last
requirement really is a huge
contributing factor towards people
missing his sign even after several
playthroughs one thing you might have
noticed in subsequent New Game Plus
playthroughs is your newly gained
ability to run through most slowing
substances such as the poison swamp in
the Shaded Castle the rivers of rot in
the helic tree and the lava in and
around volcano Manor you can move freely
through these substances without any
penalty to movement speed or role
invincibility but only if you've
progressed to new game plus there are
some instances where you still slowed
down like the blood puddle attacks from
the sanguine Noble enemies or when
you're encumbered by slug spit attacks
but outside of enemy attacks this
affords you a much faster run through of
certain areas that would have been a
much longer chore to navigate in new
game so I'm not sure if this is an
intended feature of New Game Plus but it
is a welcome one
for the next secret did you know that
some chest pieces actually have hoods
and that these hoods can fit over
certain headwear these are the
astrologer robe the perfumer robe and
the black knife armor and you can
combine these with the blood-soaked mask
the altered nox swordstress Crown the
eccentrics hood and the fingerprint help
my favorite of these is the black knife
chest with the eccentrics hood which is
the new fashion for my black knife build
that I talk about in this video by the
way and an honorable mention also goes
out to the gravekeeper and rotten
gravekeeper cloaks which have a separate
ability to display the hood over the
regular or rotten gravekeeper Helms next
deep below the Ansel well and sealed
within the yellow Annex tunnel lie the
astel these bosses that have great power
over gravity but it seems like that
power isn't just limited to them you can
actually harness that power in certain
caves as well using it to give the wing
of astel weapon a little boost so the
heavy attack and the ash of War on this
weapon both Buzz with this electric hum
when they used in locations that house
one of the monsters
specific location that this unspoken
power-up occurs in are just past the
Ansel River sluice gate the Ansel River
Main and the yellow Annex tunnel on top
of this the wing of astel does 20 more
damage to gravity type enemies in
general next is regarding the wandering
Mausoleum enemies did you know that they
have a bedtime if you wait for just the
right time of night around the wandering
mausoleums they actually stop stomping
and just don't move at all giving you
the perfect opportunity to clean up
around their legs without worrying about
being crushed by their movements seem to
take this nap around the late night time
on the in-game clock and they continue
it until the last Ray of the morning sun
touches the doll I've only noticed this
happened once and it's pretty rare
there's a deeper breakdown of the time
system here on a video by Leviathan
where he notes that late night can only
be reached after surviving 22 and a half
minutes through Nightfall without
meaning it is somewhat of a rare point
of day to reach while playing the game
you should check out leviathan's channel
for tons of Secrets like this as well
but before I go on I want to give a
brief shout out to displate as it is
almost Christmas and you might still
have time to pick up some neat gifts for
yourself or someone else so for a
limited time you can order with the link
below in the description during their
Xmas sale and get 20 off if you order
one or two disc plates or 30 off if you
order more than three on my store alone
I currently have six designs that I'm
really proud of for example there's
convergence and there's the painted
world which are full of hundreds of
souls references that will get you close
up and looking at the finer details
which is really fun there's the fire
Keeper's Apprentice there's the guardian
of moonlight to remake a demon soul so
yeah this plates are high quality Prince
uh they're really easy to mount as well
they have a sticky magnet system that
means there's no need to drill into and
damage your walls so again please click
the link below to support the channel
and get some cool art in return and
speaking of art these next few secrets
are based on the official Elden ring art
books that just came out and as always
these books give us a look into the
concept art behind the design of these
games showing weapons characters and
environments in gorgeous new detail so
one thing I couldn't help but notice was
this on page 222 of volume 1. it reveals
that in an earlier concept the forge of
the Giants wasn't a giant dish it was
instead a giant pot and honestly I kind
of love it the design here is a bit more
memorable and really playful in that way
that so many from software designs often
are and I remember reading speculation
that the giant lid that the fire giant
wields might be like a sort of lid for
the forge so I wonder if maybe the forge
having a potlit originally is kind of in
support of that idea
and speaking of a forge take a look at
this found on page 356 of volume 1. it's
a piece of concept art featuring
blacksmith huge in what is very clearly
one of the abandoned Shacks that we find
all throughout Elden ring and unlike the
giant pot piece of concept art there is
in-game evidence of blacksmith huge
appearing in this Shack and not at the
round table hold we learned this from a
cut NPC called Gilbert this character
didn't make it into retail but his voice
lines would move on to Euro and his
visual design would be assigned to witch
hunter gerund but here near the seaside
in Lim grave this NPC once told you
where to find the nearby blacksmith well
there's something you ought to know
there's an aberration of a blacksmith
past the checkpoint that leads to
stormvale it doesn't seem to think much
of anyone or anything but oddly
he's willing to Smith weapons for
tarnished the checkpoint he's referring
to is this the scavenger's shack that
stands right before stormvale here you
could have once had your weapons
upgraded and then I assume huge might
have come back to Smith for you at
Roundtable hold but a part of huge story
now in retail is that he's chained to
the round table hold so I wonder if this
story element prevented him from
appearing at the scavenger Shack
regardless cool detail and shout out to
sakuro dubi on YouTube who noticed and
showcased this long ago and the award
for the most bizarre piece of concept
art can be found here on page 148 of
volume 2. so we always knew that the
flame chariots were manned by someone
sitting at the back you can see that in
game but this is new so supposedly the
wheels are powered by people one person
for each wheel in what must be a kind of
claustrophobic hell it's kind kind of
nightmare fuel honestly and speaking of
fuel this picture actually explains why
the Chariot explodes when you do a
plunging attack from above the head is
full of flammable oil and your strike
here would completely disrupt the piping
that channels all of this to the
flamethrower
before I go I just want to say I love
all the design Works books of from
software's games some images just convey
so much like tone and atmosphere and
often a lot of that is lost when these
places are rendered in game or it's
changed at least so these are excellent
collectors items and they're very hard
to get and very expensive if you don't
buy them at launch so think about
picking up a copy now before it gets too
late I spent hundreds on the older
design Works books and yeah I regret not
getting them all at launch link below in
the description right under the link to
my displays if you're interested in
picking up even more souls inspired art
but as always thank you for watching and
I'll see you next time